[Music]
subject for today
now see i don't know if you can tell
what was going on with that slurp i was
my tongue was going side to side
oh yeah why that's a visual now this
snake
no like a serpent you know it goes out
flips
uh because she ate from the tree of good
of knowledge of good and evil
that she was a very knowledgeable
missing category i don't know why i'm
saying why she's right here with us how
are you doing there uh there uh rbg
oh hey guys nice to be here with you all
right anything that uh you know hey dave
landau is here
you can follow him on the twitter at uh
what's the twitter it's right there uh
atlanta
dave at landau dave we'll be talking
about rbg's replacement uh most likely
replacement amy coney barrett
today as well as gone to the top liberal
freakouts because we feel like we
haven't really uh
sort of hit on this now since the
election put them all in one spot and i
just found that i have a key to
something must be
very valuable underneath my mind oh wow
that's on tv well they don't know where
it is if i have no idea
well maybe they can you guys can't just
be putting keys around the place
that's to my hotel oh oh oh that's okay
i set a value so forward his hands
he just hands those out like breathing
cards that's true i am a [ __ ]
it's like i need a hundred room keys
please gerald a is
here and that's what happens at la
quinta
but they're upgrading them in best
western good yes good for them ditch
your
ritz frequent flyer card and go on down
to la
quinta rewards uh quarterback garrett
hood pass i don't care
so my question of the day here
do you think that uh the experience with
kavanaugh do you think it's changed the
way
uh sort of setting the precedent as
we're going to be uh appointing supreme
court nominations do you think that uh
what do you expect to happen right now
what do you expect to happen
with uh amy coney barrett or what do you
expect to happen there rbg
weekend at rbgs oh i don't like her very
much
i hope that uh you know trump picked
someone else
right yeah death has not been kind to
her mental acuity oh yes
she's slower i disagreed with her on
everything but she was
sharp you know for a 90 year old no not
anymore
death really takes it out of you it does
uh before
you feel sexy though it works she's
getting a little hotter
that's nice and rachel wood alternative
look
that's true it's almost like she shops
at hot topic i actually put a room key
down her shirt
minutes ago there's a studded belt in
her closet somewhere desperate
and a t-shirt that says uh i haven't had
my second cup of coffee yet so you're
not talking you know one of those oh
yeah
oh you pinterest moms who neglect your
children
it's one o'clock somewhere it's
wonderful
don't cross that line wine is just fine
yeah well no it's not
see yourself i would wear that t-shirt
he's a sommelier he wants everyone to
know all right before we move on
uh here's a clip you know we've talked
about how some some people have talked
about donald trump eroding norms yeah
right yeah we get to the supreme court
the top level of freakouts also the cdc
guidelines i don't know if you know this
they released some new guidelines about
kobe and then they removed the
guidelines and there's a conspiracy but
the truth is they just don't know [ __ ]
that's the conspiracy really is people
don't know
and we'll get to that but first let's
talk about eroding trust in american
institutions we have
ironically the straightest of the three
gay leading hosts being anderson cooper
don lemon and brian stelter
not buying it i don't want to pay
nuisance money i'm
straight swear to god
uh don lemon let's go no matter what
happens
thinking we're gonna have to blow up the
entire system what and you know what we
have to
do i don't know you know what we're
gonna yes you have to do you just gotta
honestly
from what your closing argument is you
have to get rid of the electoral college
because the people because the minority
in this country decides who the judges
are and they decide who the president is
they need a constitutional amendment to
do that and if democrats if joe biden
wins
democrats can stack the courts and they
can do that amendment and they can get
it
sacked well two thirds vote in the
congress in three quarters of the state
legislature they may be able to do that
maybe okay burn the system down then you
use the term sack
violence this guy has violence on the
brain
and then does anyone else appreciate the
irony and he said the minority
are selecting judges yeah you're right
the whole point of the electoral college
was to protect the rights
of the minority from the mob of the
majority
are you still black are you still gay
[Applause]
you're no longer a gay black man because
you're checking a few boxes
right i think the most impressive thing
is he made cuomo the lesser look smart
yeah he was like don't go there yeah go
there
pull out he's insightful uh his
insightful ginsu knife if uh you should
go out and vote
i think i put an end to uh that brush
fire
i said you say you had to have a
constitutional amendment in three
quarters of state legislature or three
quarter vote like all this stuff is like
he actually knows this
but i am looking forward very much to my
uh charity mma match with chris cuomo on
october 3rd yes
i'm excited it's going to be a lot of
fun it's going to be black i just
i just hope he shows up in in shape and
you know we'll be sure to drug test
chris
um will the money go to fixing the holes
in all the masks
they'll be going to fixing the holes in
his hgh enlarged heart
yes two sizes are the holes in his story
about having covered
or just beat a guy in a thick bike
bicycle thick thick wall
thick tires she just came out with a
shirt that says fredo yeah that was the
saddest thing or no it'll go to uh it'll
go to those less fortunate who can't
afford
uh regulation size basketball rounds ah
right
but here's the key challenge so the
reason that this matters is because
the narrative that they had been pushing
the entire uh i shouldn't say the entire
uh
presidential uh four years here really
it's just been the last few months so
throughout the four years they were
trying to erode trust and institutions
now when they say donald trump was
trying to road trust an american
institution see they see
just as valid for example the checks and
balances of three branches of government
the supreme court
the media so in other words they think
that donald trump taking aim at cnn or
brian stelter's reliable sources
is just as bad as them talking about
fundamentally changing the
constitutional parameters of government
and the supreme court
but don't take my word for it here is
don lemon
saying something to this effect that is
the president's strategy
post mueller surround himself
with cheering fans ignore lawful
requests
from congress trample over democracy
like you not burning things down the
question is
will he get away with it that doesn't
count the question is will you
let him get away with it
he just asked if you were going to burn
everything down yeah
does anyone else just get really
bothered when they act as they're
talking to you directly
if you were like will you let him get
away with it i don't know let me get the
president of the united states on my
speed dial
right i think i see one of my t-mobile
favorites
i've been saving up some rollover
minutes i've got a cricket
yes i think he was saying something
about eric holder when he lied before
congress and he was just as upset then i
think
and this isn't what about us and this is
like you're not serious like this is not
serious
again they think that they think the
most valuable the most trusted american
institution
is the media and hollywood and then they
say let's just sack the supreme court
let's burn the whole system down despite
the fact that there's a precedent
of this 29 times of a president during
an election year nominating
right someone and when it's the same
party 90 of the time if it's the same
party not a divided government like
obama when he was trying to do merit
garland with the senate
guess what it was confirmed nine out of
ten times
an outgoing president when there was a
republican or a democrat president
and the same party senate this isn't new
no it's not and the founding fathers
foresaw idiots
like don lemon and cuomo the lesser
because they were like let's make this
really hard for somebody to be pissed
off and just change the system on a whim
because they're not getting their way
let's make it hard for
five years i don't think they ever
foresaw an aging johnny mathis
gay black man talking about maybe
right on the rights of the minority like
oh that's one angry runaway
yeah they saw stupidity they foresaw
five-year-olds throwing a temper tantrum
when they don't get their way and they
said okay let's design a system that
won't let them be injured by that man
with the citrus fruit name was going to
town on the boy with a buddy whip in the
outhouse
now i've seen everything what's that
this man brian
claims that he's not a homosexual now
i've seen everything so can you imagine
a fruit named after a fruit come on
no please bananas the iron is so rich
you'll get gout as though you just ate a
bunch of fruit
i don't know if that's what works is
there uric acid come
ah i like to be blunt
apparently
it is uh by the way this is of course
donald trump has announced that he is
going to uh
he's going to announce his pick on
saturday so he announced that he's
making an announcement
uh by the way we have another 45 minutes
of show today if you have not joined up
yet
yes yeah mug club lighter with
crowder.com mug club as you know our
streams have been taken down recently
false copyrights
we don't uh pay the bills with youtube
so not only do you get the mug and more
show but it's what allows the free
content to exist and do consider
following me on the instagram
yeah uh because that's where we do what
they call a is it called lifestyle
branding is that what the kids are
calling it yeah you're a thought it's
basically just pictures of me and my
my dog and eating food ah whoa that sums
it up it's very uninteresting to me
you guys can't get enough of it
apparently yeah uh really quickly let's
go to uh cnn where jim
schudo apparently said give me the high
and tight but only on the sides
people have pandemic fatigue but the
reality is until we identify
a safe and effective vaccine through
some of these phase three studies
which why is
i don't know if you noticed that
multi-pronged swing mentally the sooner
the general public realizes that this is
not
pushing a baby and then
maybe they're trx there's a bunch of pez
dispensers on his shelf
he's a clown this is a doctor of
medicine it is seriously it looks like
jim
he went in and said give me the flock of
seagulls but i don't want to commit
i feel like he's in a van outside of an
elementary school
just with his candies and customs hold
on a second grab one of the pez
dispensers that his hand just goes out a
window
um all right so listen we have a lot to
get
to i just said cnn's not really talking
about anything but first we have to go
to uh our sponsor which
maybe that's what the key was written on
the key um very good to have them uh
it's a popping toaster uh pastries
popping toaster tarts popping toaster
tarts is the artisan alternative fruity
breakfast treat
start your morning right with a
proprietary blend of enriched flour
corn syrup high fructose corn syrup
dextrose sugar
theomen mono nitrate riboflavin sodium
acid pyrophosphate
monocalcium phosphate milled corn citric
acid gelatin caramel color soy lectin
partially hydrogenated soybean and or
cotton seed oil modified corn starch
dampened gum modified wheat starch color
added vitamin a pulmonary red 40
polyoxine hydrochloride yellow six
tricalcium phosphate flaming
hydrochloric color forecast
and blue one popping toaster tarts when
you think about it
everything's chemicals man really glad
to have them as a sponsor
they are uh we do not have a specific
brand but they can be purchased at your
store
use the crowder promo code um just say
give me all the money in the cash
register yeah yeah
and blm's no and then you get it go
look big yes like it's a bear yeah
don't play dead though don't play that
doesn't do anything they just shoot you
more
yeah yeah um so actually that might work
quick give her a lot of fetal position
all right before we get to amy coney
barrett i know a lot of you haven't been
uh
let me ask you this comment below before
we get to that segment have you been
uh familiar with no not right now
they're uh dave he has a cue here he's
not exactly sure
um have you known anything about amy
coney barrett before this but first
we just wanted to sort of clear the
palette with a top liberal freak out so
of course we all remember the freak
out uh this has sort of become old hat
at elections it's a classic
when he was inaugurated here we'll leave
this off donald j trump is now president
of the united states
and that's also why i don't buy it when
women say you don't know pain you
haven't given birth it's like but you
know what you were wincing when donald
trump became president
yeah yeah i don't think you know
it's about relative like guys have lived
their whole life where you're getting
kicked in the nuts you're getting
your rough housing like one point i
rubbed a cheese grater in my brother's
forehead when we were doing backyard
wrestling these are things that build up
the toughness
you did this like you dislocated a joint
because
donald trump became because someone lost
an election
it's painful bro it's very similar um
and this is so now we'll get some more
recent ones and sometimes these ones
a lot of them i thought were actually
fake i don't ever get this dave where
like you see the reactions now where
you're
this has to be a parody there might be
some brilliant borat type comedian a
couple of the recent ones but usually by
the end you can tell they're
psychologically broken
right yes at first you're like this is a
joke there's truth in this
we need help and we say this is two
psychologically broken people yeah
we can figure out like oh i know what
happened i know you that one's a dirty
ant
um so here's another one that i love
this is a tick tock girl freaking out
which is i'm just so glad that we we ban
it unless the deal goes through
yeah uh freaking out over pro lifers
two people that are pro-life i [ __ ]
hate you
why can't women have abortions well do
you really want to hear the reasons we
can listen to them
[ __ ] i need a visual breakdown and i
should
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you're [ __ ] stupid and i wish i had
been [ __ ] aborted oh okay
she insulted herself that's usually the
thing where people say that when you
express a pro
like i wish you'd been aborted like oh
wow great i've done open mics too
yeah well in fairness i don't want to
see her kids so if i have to know
that's how i think abortion should work
we just vote on the person right yes and
i go
i agree she shouldn't have i don't so
much i mean i also don't want to see her
kids but i really don't want to see
them crowning no no when it's crowning
is it the woman crowning or is the baby
crowning can you imagine her
screaming crap out of a woman
i wish that i never made that mistake
nothing good happens at waffle house or
the follow-up consequences
this is why i think abortion should be
reassessed at the age of 20.
yeah late we age that we should go
listen
uh you're right we should have gotten
ready well that's not too far from
rbg's views right she was a fan of the
sanger uh eugene
yeah yeah sounds was it what was your
line up there on on uh
late term abortion rbg uh i'm i'm down
for that
sounds uh right i noticed that death has
also changed your lingo uh
maybe a little bit do you feel like it's
it's up to your uh your hip game
um yeah yeah i'd say so you're about as
quick as a tick tock girl
she has the same look on abortion as uh
female chinese babies
either way there's a tub of water ah
no that's true that's when they we'll
get to the tony bear thing a little bit
but that's
when they talk about she was against
selective yeah abortion
there are a lot in china that's the idea
is they only want to have boys because
they provide for the family this idea
that it's
oh my gosh it's heinous that a woman
would not want people to be able to
abort because a baby might have a slight
defect or be
god forbid a woman it's amazing that the
left wants to dave i mean they've
already
enacted a holocaust against black
americans at this point when you look at
the millions who've been killed
and they want to do it against women yep
and that's why they have the lobster pot
[Laughter]
nothing good happens on tick tock uh
where this girl is uh complaining i
think we had to pull this from facebook
because
you couldn't find it anywhere i don't
think it was removed i think no i don't
i think the girl was ashamed
uh as she should be
shame we need to bring back shane it's a
helpful thing i'm bringing
shaymin back that's right no that's not
that is exactly
true
[Laughter]
uh here she is a tick-tock girl telling
progressive to vote for biden which
would seem benign enough not how she
does it listen kiddo
i get it i don't like the two-party
system i think our country's correct
and so frankly i don't want to vote for
biden it feels
you want to know why because the
alternative is a [ __ ] fascist
a fascist is a fascist maybe we can have
the conversation
about dismantling the two-party system
when a fascist is it
running maybe we can do that later kiddo
chiefs maybe we can talk about it later
let's talk about how your it's pat and
one of the sprockets
i don't think i think there should be
more about women growing out the pointy
like yeah yeah it's like it's like you
can't grow real sideburns
unless you're in transition in which
case good for you but they do
with the fake sideburns i don't know a
single guy he's like you know what i
want abroad with sideburns
yeah there's like you gave me the worst
beatles haircut
can you ensure no one will like me ever
can you see not quite the beatles but
the touring rain
beatles cover band i want to look like
that and here's the thing
she doesn't understand these are people
again this is an example we can examine
the behavior but let me be
truthful here that is someone who has
never had accountability someone who
sits and goes
you know what when i'm mad i do this and
doesn't have anyone going oh you look
like a you look like a lesbian
psychopath
you look like a legend domestic abusing
psychopath
when you do that and you're unattractive
and you know what get some crust
whitening mouthwash like there are just
a few corrections you commit but no one
says that they go oh you know what i can
tell you're feisty she goes i should
upload this online
this is something this is not someone
who's ever learned to control their
anger and i still raise someone
with anger issues i throw seltzer water
through the [ __ ] rock
what the heck is
[Laughter]
i too have thrown things like that last
girl threw a baby
but didn't go through the wall though
they bounced they bounced back but
you're right she has no responsibility
accountability her parents never told
her she was wrong you know her dad was
just like look just
whatever just do what you want i just
hope we have a son that wants to play
catch
at some point i can have joy in my life
because you're not providing it that's
fine i'll play catch dad i'm not raising
any san francisco
now slowly encroaching in oakland
grandchildren no you're not playing
catch with me
very disappointed dad she also has she
also doesn't understand the definition
of a fascist
she's calling donald trump the fascist
she really clearly has no grasp of
history
please tell me no one has seen my penis
today i just realized i'm wearing these
pajamas
let's start at the desk these are the
ones where what is it with pajamas does
that include the text you sent me
i'm not joking about all men's pajamas
they have the button
way up to and then the way wide hole at
the bottom
i was just feeling like oh it's kind of
drafty i thought it was because they
were these were silk
is that like the the don lemon line i'm
fine now but good lord
uh yeah i think it is just in case your
wife wants to make love and you just
want to take it out one
area right just the one yeah because
that's easy women love that when
they do and you just like yeah you will
see
no part of my body other than the weird
alien look again actually
yeah it's the same it's not even the
same color as the rest of my body
and i figured that's your thing hey by
the way if you're subscribed hit the
notification bell because subscriptions
don't mean a whole lot and
on youtube uh notifications will let you
know on your mobile device especially
because we do a lot of live streaming
right now
through maybe depending on it depending
on how susan wojcicki feels that day
yeah hopefully it's a good day for
really notifications don't go out for
four to eight days out of the month and
i don't know wow that's true quiet
really quickly it's a challenge it's a
joke you guys it's a show that's him for
fun
how's that branch
and uh here's another one where uh a
woman just recently reacted i use the
term
loosely reacted to uh ruth vader
ginsburg
alleged death holy [ __ ] [ __ ] you guys
i said this was a parody but i just got
a notification that ruth vader ginsberg
died
[ __ ] could this year get any [ __ ]
worst
ruth
she was shaking in the in her chair like
percy didn't wet the sponge
[Laughter]
and you know there's someone right there
that you don't see but there's someone
in the left
lane just like what the encouragement is
a wide swath around here that's why
young women have fewer accidents than
men
anytime i see a young woman or a teenage
woman i just i
give them as many lanes or slow down
whatever you have to and then i
inevitably drive into a pole
ah yeah actually her transitioning son
is hiding behind her
yeah i love how she gets mad at rpg for
dying you only had to make it a little
while longer you know
this woman people gave her flack for
that i think she was right
i think she was right i think rbg if she
really cared so much in other words
people are saying now the dying wish
which
thank god there's no dying wish clause
in the constitution
uh but you know i just i i think that
she was being selfish about it if she
really
didn't want president trump or someone
other than barack obama or a democrat if
she really didn't want someone
to a point before her death she should
have retired she should have been this
is
the point she's making sure i know that
charlotte but i'm just saying it's a
valid point she should have retired i
would be upset too
but this just goes to show they had they
didn't think that donald trump had any
chance of winning yeah
one more benefit of hillary clinton
losing one more benefit of hillary
clinton
i have heard that kazam might grant the
wish
[Laughter]
have you heard the mandela effect where
people think it was shazam
yeah and they're like and like
berenstein bears was different with the
i and the e i had a guy who i knew who
went off and i was like no it was shazam
like i remember seeing it it was kazam
when i even as a kid when we were
reading berenstain bears i was like this
is a very christian group for a jewish
fellow
they talk about jesus a lot yeah it's
weird in a positive light yes
not a word of traitor in here
nothing about the blood of him on our
children's children's children
mel gibson weinberg bears
have you had your fun have you had your
fun out of your system good
good all right let's go to amy coney
barrett this is the likely replacement
for ruth bader again it's slow news day
yeah
you know you saw the ride you bought a
ticket anyway
we have weekend at rbgs here okay yeah
if you're offended at this point that's
on you
uh sources have been saying that uh
president trump has
already met with amy coney barrett i
believe yesterday at the time of
depending when you're watching this
video to be clear she's a devout
catholic she's a conservative um
and she has done a lot in her legal
career while raising
seven children seven children even the
new york times i think we have this
article they notice that she has
particularly strong credentials um she
graduated summa [ __ ] laude from notre
dame
and uh she was uh scalia's favorite
while she was clerking for him so here's
actually a video from 2017 because i
know a lot of you may have never met her
may not be familiar with her during the
nomination for the seventh circuit court
of appeals i have to read this to make
sure i don't get it wrong
it wasn't the seventh um where it
if you ever wanted a more clear
depiction of good and evil like as clear
as spy versus spy in the back of a mad
magazine
here is feinstein and
bear it watch the exchange i don't have
an opening statement but i would like to
introduce my special guests
first and foremost behind me is my
husband jesse we've been married for 18
years with each year better than the
last
jesse and i have seven children as
senator young mentioned
do you consider yourself an orthodox
catholic i am a catholic
senator durbin the dogma lives
loudly within you and
that's of concern yeah she tried to say
she couldn't be a judge because she was
a practicing catholic as opposed to
well listen feinstein not all of us can
be completely unobservant jews
it is tough to do this yeah and isn't
that a religious test
right yeah yeah and that's the thing i
do i obviously have a problem with a
religious
religious litmus test the difference
between hey are you a devout catholic or
are you devout christian or jewish and
uh muslim is that the quran is a
politically prescriptive text
where it says you have to overthrow
governments you have to kill christians
and jews
you have to subject people who do not
convert to dimitut right there is an
actual
system of law the quran is a book of law
just as much as it is
a book of religion or theology but in
this case yeah feinstein i mean
you also have like tons of kids but in
catholicism you don't marry them
yeah there's a difference and you even
let them go out and select they're not
making an honest woman out of their
daughters
they have daughters on the side yes
hashtag not all muslims
uh what are we about to say they're
gonna say specifically what dogma
what uh what dogma are you talking about
because you're basically just it's like
a slur against catholicism like there's
zero chance that she's gonna list out
like oh here's my problem with you you
don't want people to die
right i think the catholic church has
been really good on their penalty or
death penalty position
they don't want you to have an abortion
and kill an unborn baby they don't want
you to have a late term abortion they
don't want you to change your mind after
you have a kid
and then murder them because you're you
know somewhat inconvenienced by their
presence now
thank you for buying his time there good
lord i was running out of words
the point stands he she wasn't being
specific she was just saying
the dogma what is it lives loudly within
you
lives whatever that means is that the
terrible movie yeah
i don't believe in things
not your best impression i'm just a jew
by
name i don't think israel has a right to
exist
i am gozer
i'm looking for the key master so that
was they were trying to imply that she
could not
be a judge because she was a christian
let me be really clear uh on kind of
what her for people who don't know some
of her policies
one is they're already bashing her right
now because she supported due process
um on campuses you know the tribe the
tribunals that people have for rape
which root like every single one i don't
know if you followed all these stories
almost every single
uh doesn't turn out very good huge
mainstream rape story that got pressed
was that uva
false mattress girl false duke lacrosse
they're false
lana dunham false uh jacob blake
sexually assaulted a woman from what we
know then violated the currently active
warrants er
and restraining order to go to her house
again where he committed sexual assault
but true let's let bygones be bygones
depending
on the uh the profile of the person
right and he turned around so he can't
he turned around and there won't be a
rolling stone article about
him actually committing sexual assault
like that right no it won't be anywhere
no they're going to be ready
and mattress girl was a perfect example
i was talking with a girl recently she
didn't know that that was fake
yeah she had no idea that there was
another guy was banned from his own
graduation
she was glenn close fatal attraction
right boiling the
rabbit she was texting him the most
profane triplex pornography you could
possibly imagine he had already brought
it to the attention of other people
saying i'm uncomfortable this girl is
stalking me right
she said rape and because she has to go
she goes out there with a mattress
carrying a mess but she's carrying the
cross
she's going out and everyone just all of
a sudden believed her and the guy his
life was ruined and there are still
people who might be hiring him for a job
interview
who think that he's a rapist even though
we know verifiably now that it's not
true just like some people still believe
that brett kavanaugh was running a train
not on flozi ford some other person who
don't remember her name at this point
and the mattress was a single it wasn't
even like a queen or anything like that
so
this is you're gonna rape someone
please continue you gotta keep it close
it's a single it
can't be a couch well she didn't have
the leg strength for a couch
i just want to say lena dunham has raped
us all visually
yeah every video she's put out yeah nice
recovery
by the way what's really unfortunate
with layne and denim i'll tell you what
i i dislike about her most
is that she claims pretty much every
rare conditioner disease yeah
like ever and she and i actually have
ehlers-danlos syndrome which you've
talked about your wife was one who
identified it right and then i went to a
doctor and got
and she's just like i have endometriosis
failures damn lows fibromyalgia diabetes
i'm a fat you know
[ __ ] so there's all these medical
conditions that have been
so i have all of them so i know what
it's like it's like you don't know one
one thing that's not on those lists of
conditions is being an adult sweetheart
yeah yes
diagnosed by dr webb md right yeah
exercise that was a long way last night
um sounds like it sounds like a gal i'd
like to have sex with
yes and leave the condom in the potted
plant which now equates to rape
you know that's the whole story with
lena dunham i
i called the guy early on i was the
first guy to reach him this was before
anyone really i
it wasn't that hard to find where she
mentioned someone's name she said it's
not a real name but
then she said he was a treasurer of a
college republican group i was able to
uh college republican
club i was able to cross-reference it
and he goes no no absolutely untrue
please don't call and bother me my wife
and daughter are here and he's just seen
he was just like so
tired of this and uh linda dunham what
happened she didn't do uh shouldn't do
anything
i don't think the statute of limitations
was up yeah she could have filed a
target all right
here's uh what do you think about that
rbg the campus tribunals because betsy
devos has caught a lot of flock for this
as someone who would support due process
should due process
also apply to uh men on college campuses
should they be afforded those rights
i think in this situation probably not
really yeah what's the precedent on that
can you they seemed like
mean young men and very uh
yeah they they didn't strike me as
upstanding
do you think though that it's a problem
this is a problem with supreme court
judges bringing their inherent
biases and yours uh being likely
anti-youth
yeah uh well yeah i'm not sure it's as
much anti-youth as
uh just um very
rude behavior right yeah party at uh
rbgs this weekend yeah
yep it's gonna be good it's gonna happen
it's gonna be a lot of fun
i'd love to listen to her for hours
bring your resistance bands
so uh there is hashtag resistance and
washington post is going after amy coney
barrett this is
it needs to be clear not only can i tell
you okay what her views are because i
know that a lot of you will agree with
that because naturally she's a more so
conservative potential supreme court
just of course yes but i think it's just
as important it's equally important to
look at the reasons
that people on the other side of the
political spectrum are attacking her
and those justifications so we talked
about how the fact that they're furious
that she supports due process right
whether you're attending cornell or not
um and she also uh made this statement
washington post couldn't believe it if
you go read the original article she
said
we should always remember that a legal
career is but a means to an end and that
end is building the kingdom of god and
to be clear she said i would never
obviously uh i would never infringe on
someone else's beliefs i would never
force my beliefs on them but oh my god
you mean that there's someone
who wants to be in the highest court in
the land who believes there's
accountability higher than the seat of
ruth bader ginsburg what a freaking
nightmare
like we couldn't have people who
actually believe that someone
else is watching them and there are
consequences beyond getting caught
right there's a sense of morality that
at least is good yeah somebody who's not
a complete narcissist and that's their
end of the entire universe and isn't it
ironic that the pretty one is the
non-narcissist
yeah she's cute interesting 100
her hair's a little fine i mean i'm not
saying
rbg here no also tough acts to follow
those are some mighty those are some
mighty tough
crocs to fill yes indeed just look at
the jawbones
i'm sure she had a couple of log cabin
abortions
i've had a few
never my wildest dreams would i imagine
that this would be my career
yes this is what you woke up for today
so let me give you some of the famous
thank you i'm sitting next to a skeleton
he's sitting next to a skeleton in a in
a man
bun with a hawaiian shirt having a good
who by the way paved the way for all
women
to follow so let's not belittle the fact
she's a hero yeah she is a hero
the best among god zero to hero like i
sex baby
yo stop um and that was it she just
stopped she just she did it
yeah her heart
like tests hot in my mind let's everyone
just stop
everyone just stop this is she's a bad
influence rbg she's a bad influence on
this show it makes us too comfortable
with what should be uncomfortable yeah
and you're a bad person
so just because i like her
it's your proximity to her so
[Laughter]
because she was a christian because she
believed that there's a higher kingdom
than god they went after the fact that
she was sort of defending due process
but that wasn't necessarily an actual
case she was involved with let's look at
the cases
with which she was involved and what her
views are um particularly listen the
important ones
as we look at this seat right now which
would sort of break up a divided court
abortion and socialized medicine
she's known of course for uh being
pro-life so that's well known that
tick-tock girl would freak out
um and this comes from i want to make
sure they have this correct comes from
the new york times amy coney barrett
meets donald trump's two main litmus
tests
she's made a cl she has made it clear
that she would invalidate the aca
affordable care act
very poorly named and take health care
away from millions of people and
undermine
a woman's reproductive freedoms this is
so funny just when you read the new york
times
the affordable care act where premiums
deductibles went up on any given year
47 yeah so it's anything but affordable
it was just an attempt to redistribute
money and by the way
i've known people who really were were
relatively poor but not poor enough
and they could get health sharing plans
far cheaper than what they would get on
the obamacare
market and then they say a woman's
reproductive so affordable care act is
uh health care that has cost americans
double or triple since it was enacted
right and reproductive freedom means
abortion up until and including after
birth according to governor blackface
himself northam yeah so
both horrible policies reproductive
freedom here's the thing i'm on board
with reproductive freedom i believe that
you have five choices you can right
contraception
abstinence adoption what are the other
choices contraception abstinence
adoption
uh i don't know that's good just
abortion is not on that list
right not killing a human being is not
on your list
basically all so here's what she wants
to do she wants to make sure that a law
that was a lie that was fought before
the supreme court that the supreme court
actually had to intervene and adjust
to make it pass right when justice
roberts didn't just see quarterback
counting on his hands yeah right
remember trying to remember his absence
i feel like you're rick perry trying to
name the three
other institutions that don't involve
ending a heartbeat yeah
exactly right and then abortion she just
wants to send it back to the states
that that those are her crazy positions
that she holds that are uh
tearing at the fabric of america
apparently if she gets on the bench yes
because the fabric of mayor of america
it's been a it's a triple
weave with dead fetuses yeah but people
are like this is america
you're talking about dead babies yeah
well i don't want to live in a country
where women can't do that well really
then yeah you have a very
poor standard of judging the country
like do you understand that we've
actually
we are the only country that fought off
the world's singular most powerful
empire one century to become the most
powerful country the next century
and not even wield it can you imagine if
the british empire right if
like that's a place like canada the
biggest land mass
available rich in natural resources
where all of their population 100 of
their population live on 10 percent of
the border and they have no
national military of which to speak
picture any other
empire okay let's go to the ottomans the
greeks the romans uh
let's go through china mongolia let's go
through
through mongolians are annoying they
needed that wall empire
donald trump in a down year would be
like our economy's struggling now let's
uh let's just go north
just let's take this if you could build
genghis khan here today
he'd be looking like oh look at this map
genghis khan i think he'd be proud of us
look
all that you see is our kingdom
what's that up there ah that you don't
want to know anything about it's bigger
than down here
lots of gold i don't know anything about
that does it uh have is it fertile
it's very fertile is it uh rife with uh
natural disasters no with the canadian
shield if you actually understand
topography really it's about as stable
in the region as you get
and you just let it be there
they must
no they're the friendliest people
they're super nice they have lots of
guns and a lot of
night sticks really yeah well at least
they must be represented by a formidable
fighting
force they sit on horses and have padded
hips
it's more of like a fun force their
money isn't even real
[Laughter]
what is money do you mean the booty yeah
in a matter of
it's see-through and colored what's a
toonie
i don't understand they still have the
queen on their
singular coin yeah yeah they do but you
don't that's because we fought off
the royalty and we establish our own
country and they they bent over yeah
they bent over
right in the keystone for the road oh
that sounds unpleasant they seem to be
doing fine with it
but yet to be clear this isn't like a
coup
you're not just going to lay low for 400
years
and then clearly take what's rightfully
yours
no genghis khan and people call you an
evil empire
have they read about me by the way i
could have any women
i wanted in my day and with the clips
i'm seeing i don't like your wig
i'll pass how were these whips
now i understand why so many of you are
gay yes
except for that stelter fellow i am
convinced
he's the genghis khan is just he gets us
in trouble he does he does
rbgs i mean
at least i didn't do it in my uh in my
stereotypical asian voice that's because
in my mind genghis khan is matt damon
now he really is uh so he's much more
intimidating than that
he went closer to pirates amy barrett
also in the cook co versus wolf uh she
supported donald trump's tighter
standards for green cards this is
something that is driving the left
absolutely nuts and again
when we say okay we want legal
immigrants to uh to be
allowed here right and we don't want
illegal listen you have to
one has to go hand in hand with the
other you can't say that we have no
illegal immigration and no immigration
whatsoever right but we we're at the
point now where okay you know what we're
mostly full and we only want to bring in
the best and the brightest that's what
happens when you're in a feeder league
versus being the top
team in the league right we get number
one draft picks at this point well
it harms the middle class american more
than anybody if you have no standards
for legal immigration you just tighten
down
illegal immigration they say by the way
as far as legal just sign the guest book
and that's enough yeah
yeah no it's not enough so she's on
board with that then there was a second
amendment case cantor versus barr she
argued that though
uh violent and i agree with this violent
offenders should be stripped of right to
own
their right to own firearms that
non-violent uh offenders should still
keep their second amendment rights and i
do agree with that i do think that's for
example if someone committed i don't
know if it's a felony but like tax
evasion
they shouldn't lose their right to
protect themselves because they probably
owe some money to some really bad people
so yeah and you should know about this
you arrested like 18 times
13. well no wow once it's over once it's
a baker's dozen
that's what i call it where's the line
for trash then 14.
felonies um well if you put three of
them together
did the court uh no fortunately oh nice
that's why
13 arrests only seven convictions wow so
yeah
i had a good lawyer 50 of the time
13 strikes and you're out this is a
whole new game but your lawyer was a
barrett
yeah and less of feinstein oh my my last
lawyer was just like i
i you're just just pay for your dui
stop come on man you're hurting yourself
and everyone you love
yeah uh it was all alcohol related and
uh drug arrests but i also i do agree
with her i mean you should get another
chance if
i've turned my life around right yeah
and 12 of those arrests were as a
juvenile while i was dealing with
something very painful at home
so there are reasons that people screw
up in their lives and i do think that
they do
deserve that second chance well and i
also um but i think it's different if
you were a gang member for example like
tooky williams who they were saying free
turkey williams let him out because
we're a children's book but he killed
four people in three separate occasions
and hold ups that person shouldn't
get their right to own a firearm back or
vote on a system of laws that they break
and i think
is it i hate to use the word common
sense but it's pretty obvious if someone
is
a kid who's made some mistakes had some
rough breaks versus someone who has
flagrant disregard for the law
in a violent fashion yeah he did
discover the berenstein crips but
i i think but you do have a point very
distasteful pop out
my personal opinion on tooky is not to
let him out they could have let him live
that's just my opinion as opposed to
putting him to death why
because i think if he was turning around
and being a better example even from
inside a cell
but he could he refuse okay he's a guy
who helped found the crips right he's
one of the
one of the original one of like the top
one of the top yeah
he has an early investor he had he had a
[ __ ] 401k
yeah he was i don't know if he was
president but he was at least vp of
sales
2000 amazon [ __ ]
and he knew these other people i think
it was four people in three separate
occasions if i'm not mistaken that he
was involved in killing
he never gave up anyone else where he
was telling kids not to join gangs like
how about you give up the names of guys
who are still recruiting them and he
refused to do that
i think it's just because prison rules
you would just die in jail you would you
could give you like a military they
could put them in you know with just
i think it's i think it's a tough ask i
really do i i i agree with you
yeah i do but you know what that's the
ask if you want to live i know but i
think he he
i think your point is correct like
prison is not supposed to be punitive
it's supposed to be you're supposed to
be
reformed and you know okay no you pay a
debt to society
i think punishment needs to this is one
thing right i think i think
prison should also be punishment put him
in the iron man yeah there's no justice
for the family if it's just like like
sweden where they go into a cell that's
nicer than an ikea demo with an xbox
and they get reformed and go back into
the workforce there's no justice for the
family
of the people who are killed there
should be punishment prisons should be
as uncomfortable as humanly possible
while they can be reformed it's not one
or the other i think it needs to include
those they should make them put together
ikea furniture they really should that
would be the best punishment for them by
far i understand the point but we're not
a vengeful society like it doesn't do
any good if somebody kills my sister for
me to know that they're suffering in a
prison somewhere
justice isn't vengeful but you're not
saying justice you're saying that it
should be as uncomfortable as possible
yeah exactly and i understand that and i
understand where that comes from but
that's not necessarily what i would want
i would want for that person to have a
better impact on society than they
currently had
if he was keeping people from then
joining said crips yeah that would be a
better use of his time than killing him
so i understand the argument but he
wasn't yeah my
my point is if it's supposed to be uh
reform
which is what prison is supposed to be
in this country yes then that means that
you get another chance i'm not saying
let you out but that means you have a
chance to do better with your life
now with uh pedophiles for example like
you said no i say kill them the second
they come in just
right yeah the doors prison rules works
very well there you kill them what you
just do is you tell them like listen
we're gonna put you in solitary you put
them in
their cell and then as soon as they go
in lights out and
all the other doors open yeah and you
say i'm gonna go out for a 35-minute
smoke break
it's more of a cigar really uh yeah the
camera's broken
and here's that make sure hear that
short circuiting sound that's the
camera's going off
have fun yeah i'll be right back enjoy
your epstein
have an epstein moment yeah they should
be epstein every time and i'm not
against the death penalty by the way so
don't take me uh wrong
i don't even care about the death
penalty so much i will say when
christians vehemently argue for against
the death penalty
it's kind of tough biblically to make an
argument you can make a valid argument
either way yeah i think whatever the
cheapest method is to dispose of the
trash
so i'm not super pro death penalty i'm
not anti-death penalty right i'm really
not against it in principle
but with our system of appeals it's more
expensive to put someone to death it's
not an effective right it's not a hill
that i'm
that i want to die on but i'm perfectly
fine if the offender does
uh i think yeah and i agree with you
actually it's just
there are the rare cases where you do
find out years later like the west
memphis three and other people that
could have been put to death that right
there are
there are problems in our system and
just killing people i think
it can have a negative but there are the
people who you're like i i watched him
eat a baby let's just kill him
right yeah there are there are those
people understand that should be put to
death but then you have different
you know that's the problems then you
have different standards of like well do
they have to be video graphic evidence
where they
listen then you are guilty of the crime
in this country it's not a perfect
system but it is
and i want to know what you guys think
actually do you think that prison should
uh involve a component of punishment and
discomfort for their crimes as justice
or do you think that it should be
like a lot of european countries where
it's only uh predicated on the idea of
reform um i think it needs to be both i
agree with
both absolutely yeah i don't think thank
you
i know i agree with that too right so i
wouldn't go that far but i'm saying
depriving somebody of their freedom is
in itself punishment what you do with
that making them put together ikea
furniture or letting them go to a beach
there's two different things there and i
wouldn't say the beach i would say the
ikea furniture
is what you lean towards right not
solitary confinement and not like
horrible conditions i want these people
to come out better hopefully than they
went in and that is
not normally give just give conjugal
visit rights to the
uh streaming on tick tock right yeah it
can't just be pablo escobar where
they're like hey we put some bar windows
right
yeah exactly
the army's here to serve you sir what
shall we do put some chicken wire
on your third story windows and uh we
dug a tunnel in your cell so
yeah enjoy dying on your roof
also a couple changes of uh tight
hawaiian shirts we figured that
you'd be happy about that and i would
like you to soon
return to running our government that's
fantastic um hold on a second right now
cnn right now they're talking about the
grim milestone of 200
000 deaths and 50 plus 16 reporting
between 10
and 50 percent higher infection rate
this week than last oh look he's a
weather man
we're going to see a lot of nursing
homes coming in through the northeast
that's kind of gross
and then you'll see mostly young here so
it's yellow you know
what they're happening in the middle of
yeah exactly yeah a couple of sneezes i
heard they're not mixing these are
hemorrhoids here you can pretty much
ignore that i don't know why that's on
that map
nobody cares anymore yeah no they're not
mentioning hospitalizations they're not
mentioning icu patients they're not
mentioning deaths right now they're only
mentioning a total
that is creeping up for three days
they've been like we're about to cross
the line for you
and dave i don't know how much you watch
the show and i hope not all that much
i'm always amazed that you guys watch
and i'm very grateful i prepare so much
from like
really folks are gonna watch this and
support it thank you um
but flu season you know when people say
oh this is a bad season 80
000 people died that's because we have a
standardized season season right it's
from
spring sorry from fall to spring i
believe it's october to
it's either october may yeah or october
to march or september to april something
like that
and i said this before i said listen if
you want to know that this is obviously
uh fear-mongering from the media
they're just going to have a
never-ending toll long after the flu
season
that's what they're doing nowhere else
with a flu season which by the way at
one point we would have been banned on
youtube but now the cdc has admitted
that the death rate
is far more close to the standard flu
than it is to the
over one percent that they originally
claimed we don't do this with flu season
we don't do this with any other
seasonal uh disorder any other seasonal
disease but they just keep
adding to it even as we go into the next
fall we
should have restarted well if they're
going to pick this lane to go down and
say 200 000 this rolling count
fine fine let's let's stay in that lane
that means that donald trump has
lowered the projected death count by 90
percent by his actions because you said
2 million when we first started
right you said 2 million it's 200 000.
90
lower than estimated every possible and
that's everyone who's died with covid
even if they had cancer diabetes in
stage renal failure i was talking to my
wife
like elliot smith in a motel 6. yeah guy
got shot in the
in the head and died from that and he
also had coveted yeah i think it was
florida i can't remember where i got
into a motorcycle actually motorcycle
three times the legal limit of alcohol
in his system
and he happened to have covered uh he
didn't feel it and that's the only way
that people were getting funding though
i mean i've talked to a lot of nurses
and doctors like that's what we have to
do we have to market covert market covet
and what is it six percent of the people
didn't have a pre-existing condition
and the average was 2.6 conditions for
the average cova death the average age
in most states is above life expectancy
let's go to uh the
scientist the uh single authority in
chief who's got no strings to hold them
down
we don't want no let me get to this the
cdc this is another story and then we're
going to go uh behind the table where i
will show dave lander the funniest thing
i've ever seen
and take your chat uh but the cdc did a
flip-flop here so this is one thing that
really bothers me when people just say
well trust the experts
on a second are you an expert and is dr
burke's an expert what about all of the
other scientists who are actually
qualified or doctors who practice
my god medicine right yeah i thought she
hasn't seen a patient in several decades
and look up the history of fauchian aids
and just how wrong he was there
it's hilarious it reads like a joke
novella
like we would write it yeah it reads
like when oprah said one in three
heterosexual couples will die of age by
1995.
it's almost like that so the cdc though
is flip flop this is a recent one and
then let me
explain to you why um it's not that i
don't trust scientists it's that i trust
the scientific method
and time and time again we see certain
scientists who are not
observing the scientific method case in
point this just happened on friday right
um
the cdc posted new guidance that aerosol
transmission may be one of the most
common ways so what happened was they
posted they updated new guidelines
the cdc saying that actually it can be
an aerosol meaning not droplets so
this is a problem that can occur more
than six feet away basically
covid now is completely airborne that
can occur anywhere and so we need to
have enhanced filtration systems
and different methods and then they took
it down fear
then they took it down uh our bed yeah
so it went up
they changed they were right down and
then pelosi was challenging the cdc
blaming trump
himself for the reversal again this is a
problem what do you think hap the
scientific method is we think it might
be a va we think it might be air assault
oh wait no we're wrong about that we're
going to correct it how dare you correct
it when we want science do you know
what's uh
do you even science bro well at this
point any changes they make they're
saying it's because donald trump is
putting political pressure on them to
make him that the cdc is now an
organization that we can't trust right
really donald trump's tumblr
right yeah exactly don't even know if
you can we should wear a mask or not
we discovered nothing even when i first
heard that i was an industrial painter
they're like we're not sure if it
protects it i'm like
so you were you protecting the paint
when i was wearing them
we are not even we know nothing about
this well never before
i'm sorry go ahead but you can't trust
it you can't trust
assumptions that's just the reality and
you're like same with oprah it's like
hindsight
you know everything they said was
ridiculous and a huge heidi
yeah yeah hindsight well some of the
time
it's like month to month you have no
idea but she's going to be on the cover
of her own magazine
you can track it from the magazine and
msnbc even went as far as
uh saying that this was a battle because
the cdc did this put it up
took it down msnbc said this is a clash
of politicians and scientists here's a
clip
what does this tell us about how the
administration is handling the pandemic
now
this is in line with a stream of of
things we've seen where there seems to
be a real battle
inside the cdc between the scientists
and the political appointees
i mean over and over again we've seen
the cdc pushing forward
um or silencing the the scientists
um accusing them
that the president wants to be sending
of trying to embarrass him okay
okay all right listen no no no no no no
i can't
but [ __ ] have to push it back down
like swallowing a little bit of vomit at
this point
they were saying you should trust
anthony fauci why because the cdc
is a separate completely separate wing
of government autonomous from the
presidency they're the ones who set up
this clash
donald trump and anthony fauci get along
they bust both
all the time they're constantly ripping
each other so they said don't trust
anything coming out of the white house
don't trust anything coming from
politicians trust the cdc trust future
don't trust any of the other scientific
experts
first was trust the imperial uh imperial
college of london but trust the cdc
because
it is not tainted with politics which of
course is also untrue but that's what
they told you and now they want you to
believe
that donald trump is basically treating
the cdc like his own personal blog spot
well let's go through this really
quickly you mentioned masks
here's why some people might not trust
the scientists and again that's a
flip-flop from the media trust the cdc
they're autonomous trust the scientists
hey
don't trust the cdc because right now
they actually decided to use a
scientific method and realize that they
may have been wrong or jumped the gun
what else have we had on uh the cd flip
flops wear mask
don't wear a mask you can go back to the
show where we actually had origin main
a company retooled its factory put on
master we said listen we don't know if
it works or not but we do think that it
probably helps from the science that
we've seen
if you have the sniffles to prevent it
from transmitting to other people
we were sick checked on youtube that
masks actually don't help and that they
could hurt
at that point in time then they said
it's airborne it's not airborne that's
the more recent one there was a
mortality rate of
over one percent some people had it as
high as four percent now to
zero point two percent if you're below
the age of eight and don't have
pre-existing conditions it's like
point zero three percent people were
removed on facebook those doctors in
california
for expressing exactly the mortality
rate that is the newly revised not even
newly you know several months
in now revised mortality rate from the
cdc
so when actual scientists are out there
saying actually we think that this is
the mortality rate
what happens they get removed from
facebook then when the cdc catches up
because it's a giant bureaucratic
bloated [ __ ] bag
all of a sudden we accept their
mortality rate but that doesn't change
the fact that you don't get it back
those doctors have been banned from
facebook those people who've been trying
to actually
perform a public service just like we
don't get our live stream back what else
asymptomatic people
uh can be carriers to uh asymptomatic
people can't be carriers
back to actually they can be carriers so
that's another flip flop
experts though they're experts my
personal favorite trust the scientists
mass gatherings at churches even outside
in the park worship
or voting dangerous cannot be tolerated
mass protests in the street where you
burn rubber
literally i don't mean that driving fast
i mean you actually burn
rubber and throw bricks through windows
and get tear gas
all of a sudden we're a little murky on
the science we don't think that's as
much of a problem as people singing
uh uh lord i lift your name on high in a
local park
well it i think the problem that we all
have now is that this has been
politicized but they're saying that it
was politicized by republicans no
it was politicized by news agencies who
wanted to push fear-mongering so that we
could have
donald trump be responsible for hundreds
of thousands of deaths so that he
wouldn't be voted again as president of
the united states and put back in office
no that that you guys are the ones that
have gone out there and made us not
trust in these institutions
because you haven't gone with common
sense we've known for a hundred years
that mass don't work
right we've never had let me recap this
so at the beginning of this
two million deaths mortality rate of
single percentage
uh single-digit percentage points one to
four percent masks are a bad thing
asymptomatic people can't be carriers it
was uh not
airborne and now at the end of this
revised about
a tenth of the death rate you absolutely
have to have masks the mortality rate is
not single digit it's point
zero single digit uh and uh we still
don't know about asymptomatic carriers
or if it's airborne your guess is as
good as ours trust
the science and by the way don't conduct
any of your own science and don't even
actually try and
aggregate science from multiple sources
guess what
if oh my god if you actually looked at
other science aside from the number one
the only science that was accepted on
facebook twitter youtube what was it the
imperial uh college of london
yeah and if you went against it in any
way and that guy has been forced to
resign in shame if i'm not mistaken
if you want to get kneel right yeah if
you went against it in any way
you were removed from misinformation
well now the science
has caught up to the critics yeah who
let's look at
who was the ex the expert at that point
right was the imperial college of london
and even anthony fought you saying two
million deaths they said it could be
anywhere from
at least one percent one two and uh some
people are having it as high
as four percent one or two percent the
people who said you know what i think
this is actually really
a glorified flu with glorified flu has
point uh 0.1 or 0.01
right well okay this was at the
beginning people who said this is more
comparable to the
flu than it is to say ebola uh were
banned
now who was right it's not even close no
the people who said it's closer to the
flu if you were to have it on a stick
graph
the truth would be so far over you would
really just think it's a line with a
double dot at the end of it
yeah and go back and replay one of the
videos that we did during the quarantine
that we did we said if you would just
protect old people with pre-existing
conditions you would be going further
than doing any lockdowns and doing any
masks
any social differences those are the
people that are stressed yeah just
in prison old and sick people just lock
them down
for a little while and it is odd we let
ebola people off of a cruise ship
faster yeah yeah and we
vilified the was it samaritan americans
first who went over there into uh those
countries with ebola
there was a 50 mortality rate yeah one
if you're talking about politicizing
it's very hard to trust anybody once it
was the russia
kavanaugh and then this thing it just
fell so perfectly like dominoes you're
going to make american people distrust
it are you saying that kavanaugh didn't
run
trains on unsuspecting women on the
weekends well i'm just not her
you can't have an opinion i don't
believe unless you have ovaries i forgot
about that that's
right no the band is well warranted all
right finish it up then we're gonna have
to go to uh buckle
i know it's been a bit of a slow news
day unfortunately i think that's going
to change we're hearing that uh the
louisville kentucky has actually issued
a state of emergency because they're
about to announce something about the
brianna taylor case
do we have any updates hey
from remote right now do we have any new
news on this before we leave louisville
kentucky is about to actually uh
well i don't know when they're going to
announce but they've actually already
declared a state of emergency
like people are taking stuff out of
their office building people right
at the draft right because they're
because they're going to make an
announcement people have to declare a
state of emergency because people are
going to lose their minds hey how much
do you want to bet that it doesn't
matter what the announcement is
no shit's going to get burned yeah oh
yeah i bet there's gonna be a lot of
prized horses on fire
all i hope is that they just don't make
it to the wild turkey distillery that's
all true
uh all right it's a shame though yeah
they're going to they're gonna light it
up it doesn't matter it's
so stupid it's like a college that wins
or loses a basketball game yeah it
doesn't matter no no it's a canadian
hockey player
yeah they would write it's like the
second you had heard that they made the
playoffs yeah you got some digital locks
and safe
even if they win they're gonna ride win
they're gonna riot if they're gonna lose
they're going to riot
and uh you know what here i love you
guys let us know where you line up we
had a few questions today about capital
punishment if you trust the science
uh and uh what you think is going to be
happening going forward the supreme
court uh we also have
your chat to read and the funniest thing
i've ever seen i want to see what dave
landau thinks
right now those who are mug club only
you two um
you know i've not even no compliments
i'm trying i've been trying to do the
compliment sandwich
you suck goodbye